all right i want to check in briefly
with you guys about the comedy of errors
that are donald trump's sworn affidavits
some of which are arguing in michigan
that the results in minnesota towns
prove michigan voter fraud now if if you
just heard me say that and you're
confused you should be confused it makes
no sense
and i'm going to explain it to you let's
back it up a little bit
for weeks now trump and people around
him including his lawyers
continue to refer to supposedly sworn
affidavits
signed under penalty of perjury from all
sorts of different people
that prove that there was voter fraud
now i've already talked to you before
about
affidavits as evidence affidavits are a
form of evidence
it could be trustworthy it might not
affidavits might be credible or they
might not affidavits might be admissible
or they might not they're not
proof of anything per se but when you
actually
start looking at some of these
affidavits it becomes
cartoonishly farcical here is one such
example this is just one now they claim
to have i don't know if it's thousands
or tens of thousands of these sworn
affidavits of people
reporting wrongdoing in mathematical
anomalies or anomalies as your
preference may be for pronunciation
but let's just look at one okay there's
an affidavit from a guy named
russell ramsland who is a supposed
expert on cyber security
in his affidavit russell attacks
dominion software which is used on some
voting machines
and it claims that there is very
suspicious activity
in some towns that are in wayne county
michigan and in their list of towns in
wayne county michigan
they list places like spruce grove
township
and atlanta township and roonberg
township
all of those places are not even in
michigan
as jake tapper from cnn pointed out on
twitter
spruce grove township is in minnesota
atlanta township is in minnesota
roonberg township is in minnesota
now one argument was
this was supposed to be evidence from
wayne county
minnesota not wayne county michigan so
the
everything's accurate it's just they put
mi
instead of mn and that's why all of the
towns that are listed
are actually in minnesota instead of in
michigan
that doesn't pass the sniff test because
there is no wayne county
in minnesota so what we have here is
if we want to be as charitable as
possible
we have incompetence if we want
to maybe think of a less charitable
interpretation
these are straight-up fraudulent
affidavits the idea that they
submitted these uh knowing that these
are not even actually places in michigan
and they were hoping to deceive courts
and hoping to move some of these bogus
lawsuits forward we don't know
we may never know it's increasingly
irrelevant
this evidence supposedly from michigan
was submitted as part of a filing in
georgia
the georgia results are moving forward
and
they it was supposedly data from
michigan michigan has also now been
certified and put
officially in joe biden's column so it
is all failing but this is why you know
we really have to go beyond
there's this idea of just throwing large
amounts of stuff at the wall
and seeing what sticks and i've talked
about this before in debate
it's something called the gish gallop
you you throw a bunch of stuff out there
and just make it appear overwhelming and
make it difficult for
whoever you're trying to convince to
really go step by step
step and refute this the equivalent of
the gish gallup is just getting
thousands or tens of thousands of signed
affidavits and
you know holding them up as stacks of
paper as trump cronies have done on
television inc
including his press secretary kelly
mckennony but what you really need to do
is not say wow if there are ten thousand
of these things or a hundred thousand or
five thousand whatever
there must be something to it you just
have to dive in and start looking at it
and saying okay
let's look at this one affidavit and
then you look at it and you say
this really is nothing this is really
hearsay it doesn't really tell us
anything about
uh there being fraud it's an allegation
in many cases an allegation which even
if true
would not impact the results of this
state and you put that aside
and then you look at the next one and
then you look at this one and it lists
towns supposedly in michigan that are
actually in minnesota
and then you start eliminating it and
what do you have left you have left the
realization that joe biden won because
he got more votes in enough states
that's really it
and um these we rest assured
we're not going to have to hear that
much more about affidavits
for too much longer